hello everyone and welcome to the match
you've all been waiting for i announced
some week ago that i was going to
publish this uh if you remember uh i've
paired the last week i've paired the
stockfish 14 powered by uh the
efficiently updatable neural network or
backwards nnue and i've paired it
against the old chess master that was
running on the nintendo entertainment
system so it was pretty much an overkill
it was a wild game and i've made quite
an introduction so you guys would know
what's happening even if you are not
you know into computer chess so if you
by any chance haven't seen it do check
it out it will be the first link in the
description below so you kind of get um
into the mood for this one because now
we have the absolute latest version of
the grand master it is the chess master
grand master edition from 2007 and uh
the uh well uh now the old chess master
but the newer old chess master has come
to
exact his revenge on the on the uh well
the deadly stalk fish will this be
possible uh now for the first game i
decided to give stockfish the white
pieces then if you guys uh will insist i
will also give chess master the white
pieces i just wanted to see how it would
play out and in those days they claimed
that chess master uh the grand master
edition was rated some 3 000
and something so i i thought it would be
a you know a fairly boring long match uh
but was i wrong so
we can
discuss this all we want but uh we are
definitely here to see the game so uh
let's dive straight into it like i said
i made a quite a long intro in the
previous video regarding this match so
do check it out first link in the
description below now let's check it out
stockfish 14 powered by the efficiently
updated
neural network uh also having access to
a database uh and uh also having access
to the leeches cloud analysis uh uh
software uh uh
uh uh mode so sort of sort of saying uh
and if you guys don't know what that is
i also explained that in the previous
video but basically if you guys had some
friends or you were having a party or
something and you analyzed a certain
position of the evidence gambit and
forgot you know that the
computer was still analyzing it and then
you might have analyzed it up to depth
60 for example which is uh the the depth
let's say the norwegian supercomputer
says a uh
is analyzing when they're analyzing the
games magnus carlsen is playing then
someone else who logs on to leeches
opens up an analysis board and if they
put in that exact same position uh they
will have the analysis available to them
immediately at the depth 60. so if
you're using leachate analysis that's
definitely something to consider turning
on a cloud analysis that way uh we help
uh everyone uh who is using it so you
know you don't have to waste a lot of
time if you know a lot of people are
analyzing the berlin uh we we get
instant answers so uh now let's check
out the game as now you guys uh uh
understand what that is so stockfish 14
uh opens with pawn to e4 again stockfish
always wants to play the rating but i'm
not a big fan of daretti i've never
studied retti and i i you know yeah i i
just don't want to watch our 80 games so
that's why i made the first move for
stockfish in case you guys are wondering
why there's an e4 on the board emini for
player so that's why i made stockfish
play e4 but all of the other games or
all of the other moves are the moves
they make themselves
so chess master uh grand master edition
replies with pawn to e5 we have knight
to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to b5 we
have a6 going for the morphe defense and
bishop to a4 we have pawn to b5 yeah
this is um
and nowadays knights to f6 and d6 are
the are the main ideas but here uh chess
master goes for pawn to b5 it's still
very much played only maybe not at the
absolute highest level where we have
certain answers from our good friends
the engines so here bishop to b3 knight
to f6 and the immediate pawn to d4 this
is a very very sharp line uh that
stockfish is playing e captures on d4
and now just castles yeah so the pawn
will be recaptured you have really no
good way of um stopping this so now
basically chess master has to decide
whether to go into this very well known
line of knight captures on e4 and rook
to e1 which really hasn't been
all that great for black or to just
continue with pawn to d6 and pawn to d6
is the way to continue if you play
something like bishop to c5 you try and
defend the pawn uh that's not gonna work
because now for example e5 and black is
very very close to resigning there's no
good way to defend this position for
example if knight g4 just c3 and now how
are you playing this
uh you
best for black is just to play b3 and uh
give white a better position because if
you play something like the captures on
c3 then queen d5 threatens checkmate and
you're going to lose the bishop so
uh be careful when developing the bishop
like that so pawn to d6 of course chess
master is a very strong
i'm not going to
do something that silly knights to g5
and now knight to e5 uh defending the
the f7 pawn but sort of inviting this f4
move by stockfish and okay stockish
plays it pawn to f4 and now knight the c
for blocking the bishop here saying okay
uh if you want to give up your light
square bishop you spent like five tempi
getting it to b3 that is perfectly fine
by me so e5 by stockfish we have d
captures on e5 and now there are some
games in the database where f captures
and e5 was played but here stockfish
plays bishop captures on c4 and it is
now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so one thing that
chess master grand master edition isn't
taking into consideration is that it was
published in 2007 and stockfish 14 with
all of this power is running um
well in in 2022 so there's a 15-year
difference uh of uh you know uh things
that were improved in chess engines and
uh well when it comes to brute force
calculation uh stockfish will definitely
have the upper hand so b captures on c4
and now f captures an e5 saying you
cannot move the knight otherwise the f7
pawn falls but now uh uh
chess master goes into a a beautiful
beautiful attacking formation bishop to
b7 we have e capture sun f6 stalkfish
grabs the knight here g captures now
attacks the knight and now rook to e1
with check we have bishop the e7 and now
knight to e4 going after knight captures
on f6 as the bishop will be pinned but
here grand master edition of chess
master a goes for pawn to h5 and now
what is happening here is knight
captures on f6 an option of course it is
in starfish plays at night captures an
f6 check king to f8 and now how do you
continue this game uh if you if you give
a chess master a few moves for example
you move the knight um it's not going to
be all that great let's say knights d4
queen to d5 comes and now this is very
scary this is uh this is going to be a
problem rook is coming to g8 this is
going to be a problem if the knight
moves further bishop to d6 this might be
a problem uh the pawns here controlling
all of these squares this could be a
problem so stockfish has to calculate
this perfectly but that's exactly what
stockfish does best and here after king
to a fate stockfish plays queen to d2
what a spectacular move
point is that
now if bishop captures an f6 you of
course will play
queen to b for check and pick up the
bishop on b7 but that's the only move
that uh
chess master has if chess master doesn't
capture the knight let's say just master
play something like d3 and it's a move
at some point you want to play yeah it
does create a pass pawn uh stockfish had
in minded this beautiful queen sacrifice
queen the h6 with check i did it in slow
motion right away so i don't have to
repeat it but here only one move rook
captures and bishop captures will be
checkmate as the knight covers e8 and g8
so unfortunately for chess master only
move is bishop captures an f6 so bishop
captures an f6 and now queen the b4 with
check going after the bishop on b7 king
to g7 queen captures on b7 but not just
pawn to d3 and here it's like a
chess master is saying okay you uh you
you have won a piece but uh don't you
know in i mean uh do they not teach
engines in in 2022 that you also have to
develop your pieces what is this
what kind of a queen side is that and if
you face chess master from this position
with the white pieces you would probably
get crushed however stockfish one thing
that it's really good at that's
calculating brute force lines so we have
c3 here uh not allowing any any action
along this diagonal and now queen to d6
preparing to bring the rooks into the
game queen back to f3 by stockfish and
now rook ate the e8 now you're preparing
rook capture sunny one so rook to f1
putting uh pressure on the bishop and
now rook to e6 now grand master edition
of chess master will bring the other
rook here
double rooks on the e file and then
claim it doesn't matter you're up a
piece i have a pass deep on how will you
fight against this so bishop to f4
stockfish has to give up something uh it
has to allow queen to b6 with check and
the loss of the b2 pawn if it's the
develop any pieces whatsoever so queen
to b6 check king the h1 and now queen
captures on b2
not just master just threatening to pick
up the rook here so knight the d2 and
everything is nicely defended here and
the real question is can you capture on
c3 if you can capture on c3 then the two
pass pawns will definitely be um
incredibly difficult to deal with
problem is if you play queen captures
then rook to c1 then the pawn falls uh
this will not be all that impressive so
instead rook h the e8 just doubling up
rooks on the e file preparing rook to e2
which will put more pressure on g2 which
will uh put pressure on the knight here
so how can stockfish continue this rook
a to b1
attacking the queen queen captures an a2
and now only now queen captures on h5
and now
what do you play the problem is this
beautiful rook to e2 idea does not work
if you play rook to e2 then stockfish
has a forced checkmate starting with
bishop to h6 check and after king the g
it just rook captures an f6 and this
really leaves you without a move just
queen g5 followed by queen g7 will be
checkmate and if you try rook to e1 with
check uh then we just bring the rook
back rook to f1 rook captures rook
captures uh and now for example rook to
e7 you have to defend somehow but queen
g4 and you get checkmated king h8 or h7
and queen to g7 will be checkmate so
after queen captures on h5 chess master
says i'm just gonna play king to g8 and
there's no way uh you can you can do
this uh bishop to h6 and now we have
bishop captures on c3 a beautiful move
by chess master allowing queen captures
on f7 queen captures on f7 and knocking
to h8 and here chess master is saying uh
okay you have something here but with my
rooks covering the sixth rank the eighth
rank and with my uh bishop covering this
diagonal uh it's uh it's not that you
can't deliver checkmate you can't even
deliver one check so how is stockfish to
play this well stockfish just shows why
why it is uh feared by everyone and why
it is so incredibly strong and why every
chess game basically comes down to the
b4 square stockfish plays rook to b4 and
what is this what is this move look at
this uh bishop can capture the knight
here bishop can capture the rook here
problem is if the bishop ever moves from
this diagonal you just get checkmated so
of course uh uh that's out of the
question and here uh stockfish is
basically saying i'm just gonna capture
a pawn and then uh you know i'm just
going to win more material and win the
game i don't have to check matey or
anything so here rook six to e7 chases
away the queen queen the h5 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries king the g8 and now queen to
g4 with check we have bishop back to g7
and now queen the g6 with a very simple
threat of bishop captures rook captures
and then you just gobble up the rook
here and the problem is there is no good
defense against this uh for chess master
whatever you play uh we're uh next movie
if you move the rook uh something like
queen g5 attacks the rook will will be
deadly and if uh
rook to d8 which was played in the game
here just bishop the g5 by uh stockfish
uh so both rooks are now hanging rook to
a8 we have bishop characters on e7 and
now queen captures on d2 now the past
pawns might start marching forward uh
but it is far too late because there is
a beautiful beautiful uh move here that
just ends the game uh there are many
moves that in the game here for
stockfish but there is actually a forced
checkmate in eight moves so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
quickest way of winning this for
stockfish while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting any of
the winning moves like queen f7 queen to
e6 rook captures and c4 like pretty much
any move you make here will win the game
but the only uh quickest way to win and
that's a forced checkmate in eight moves
is rook f2b1 so uh in case someone
actually paused the video here and tried
to solve this congratulations you are a
a true engine when it comes to solving
chess positions uh and there is no
defense uh
rook the rook to b8 will just end the
game so here the only defense is queen
captures on b4 which was played in the
game bishop captures on b4 we have king
the h8 so still uh of course uh
chess master will put up some resistance
but now rook to f1 we have pawn to d2
bishop captures now comes rook to b8 of
course just making silly moves rook to
f7 and now rook to b1 with check it
would be uh
checkmate if uh you didn't have queen
captures on b1 but luckily for stockfish
there is this move and i'm sure some of
you might even have missed this so queen
captures on b1 uh chess master
prolonging the game for as long as
possible pawn to c5 and now queen to g6
and next move you will get checkmated
pawn to a5 was played here queen
captures on g7 and that's it uh chess
master survive for 43 moves and um like
i said i thought it'd be a much much
more boring game and you know some sort
of berlin that you know
lasts for 150 moves but chess master
decided to go for a very very sharp line
uh only problem is like i said uh chess
master was unaware of the fact that it
was playing an opponent
that had uh
you know 15 years
more advanced software and the stockfish
was just brutal brutal in calculating
this when i saw when i saw this queen
today move i saw i thought maybe i uh
rushed uh or you know rushed to the
position a bit and you know stockfish
just played a silly move but then of
course when queen the h6
uh came i was like wow that's uh that
that's truly truly impressive i i think
the most beautiful move of the game
definitely queen to d2 threatening queen
h6 and queen before if the bishop moves
uh truly truly outstanding uh so yeah uh
chess master was unable to
exact revenge on its uh previous version
of the nes chess master we'll see if you
guys are interested what will happen if
the chess master gets the white pieces
and stuff which gets the black pieces i
think it will be it could also be a very
interesting game uh but uh
you know
if you guys want to see it i i would
very much enjoy making a video on it so
you know do say something in the
comments like you know
justice for chess master or something
like that you can even be creative uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by stockfish
and uh i i i have to say i was very very
uh glad when i when i saw the chess
master grand master edition once again
it brought back so many great memories
and if you guys have an opportunity to
somehow grab hold of this program do uh
make use of it it has a brilliant
brilliant academy uh you know just just
the the the one with with um the the
josh weightskin academy is so incredible
it teaches you like everything how to
think how to how to play in games how to
how to attack in chess it's amazing uh
you know a resource if you want to
improve your chess so you know do
consider acquiring it uh so yeah that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank brian enriquez
krishna kumar john anderson lucian rozav
and akshay pandit for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day